Welcome to our strength
test, bladesmiths.
I'm gonna to take your blades
and beat them repeatedly
into these railroad spikes.
I want to see what the spikes
are going to do to your blades.
John, you're up first.
You ready?
I'm nervous as hell.
My knives are thinner
than the others.
So I don't know if I can hang.
[beating, grunting]
(WHISPERING) Holy crap.
No kidding.
Well, John, not bad.
You got a little edge
damage, a little deformation,
a little too soft on this one.
This edge, not bad,
a little brittle.
This one held up the best.
Overall, you survived
the strength test.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Duane, how you feeling?
Let's do it.
[beating]
[exhales out]
All right, guys.
All right, Duane.
We got a bit of a problem here.
The edges on your blades
aren't as hard as we hoped.
We don't have chipping.
The steel is actually
compacted in on itself.
Drew.
You're up.
How do you feel?
- Nervous.
- Nervous?
That's all right.
I'll be over in a minute.
I'm completely
distraught inside.
I'm trying to calm myself down,
doing some deep breathing,
and I'm just stressed
out like crazy.
[beating, grunting]
All right, Drew, your
blades are actually
very comfortable, except for one
point, these hooks back here.
There's sharp corners on
there, and that actually
built bit Dave's hand here.
Right here.
The edges took some damage.
For the most part, your
blades held up well.
So good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, it's
time to see what kind of edge
your blade still have.
A sharp edge should cut easily.
A rolled edge, it might snag,
or worse do nothing at all.
John, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I'm ready as I can be.
[slashing noises]
All right, John,
all your blades
have areas that are
sharp and some areas
that aren't as sharp.
On the inside of the
canvas, your blades cut.
But on the thick edges, they
had a hard time cutting through.
But all your blades will cut.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Duane, your turn.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[slashing noises]
All right, Duane, overall,
there's a lot of damage
in all the edges, and it shows.
Your blades pretty much hang
up and rip into the canvas.
They didn't cut.
Overall, your blades will rip.
All right, Drew, your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[slashing noises]
All right, Drew, there
are some areas here
that are damaged, and
it's exactly those areas
that hung up on the canvas.
But overall, your
blades here will cut.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, for one of
you, your journey stops
dead in the tracks right here.
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Duane.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Yeah, Duane, though I
like the diversity of blades
you made for us, your
knives suffered the most
damage in the strength test.
And that was really made
apparent in the sharpness test.
So that's why we're
letting you go.
Duane, please
surrender your blades.
I'm pretty disappointed,
but I'm going to go
home with my head held high.
I'm very happy with what
I've accomplished here.
I'm looking forward to getting
back out in the shop with Dad
and working on some knives.